foreign
is with us in Seattle hi Allison welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it sure what's up
um I just have a question for you
um a long time I'm a long time listener
we've listened for about 10 years
and I just am curious about your own
personal story when you went through
bankruptcy
it seems like if I understand correctly
you became a millionaire pretty quickly
after that or if I'm incorrect maybe I'm
incorrect on that but I just am
wondering how how did you do that it
just it seems so slow to pay off our
mortgage and so I'm a little bit
discouraged like I see all these young
kids on YouTube you know doing all of
these I don't know investment type
things where they're built like buying
duplexes living in half of it
you know I forget what that's called but
I'm curious it just seems so slow okay
okay uh no it was about 10 years
for us 10 years um
uh we filed bankruptcy in 1988 it was
probably about 98 or even the year 2000
somewhere in there before we hit a
million dollar net worth I guess I've
never gone back and looked at it but
it's somewhere like that it was not it
wasn't that fast uh what do you make
what's your household income
about 105 000 okay and uh how has that
increased over the last 10 years
quite quite a quite a bit I mean okay my
husband I think he started around
65 maybe yeah okay
um and so you you have just your home
left to pay off
yeah it's it's
worth market value right around 7
. okay
all right but we don't have any
intention of selling it so yeah I didn't
want you to sell it I just was asking
what was going on okay so you got a you
got a 700 000
uh you know piece of net worth there and
you've also got surely you've been
saving for uh retirement through that
time right
yeah we we do the 15 in 401k and Roth
IRAs yeah and how much is in there
I don't know I haven't checked that for
a while oh roughly
uh
maybe two
maybe 200 150 200. so maybe you're a
millionaire and you just made 100 Grand
Max
that's pretty good
well I don't know about I don't know
well I mean if you're if you did if you
have 250 000 in your 401ks and you have
a 750 000 equity in your house that's a
million dollars
yeah
yeah I guess maybe yeah let's assume
that you have a fast forward button
because I'm hearing some angst here I'm
just curious if you fast forward
crap get rich quick stuff on the
internet and you thought there was an
easier way to do it than you've been
doing it with the income you've had
you've done an amazing job
what do you want on the other side of
this what's on the other side of paying
the house off let's assume you've done
that what do you want
you know I really don't know I've kind
of asked myself that question as well I
just I think I think I come from a long
line of on both sides of my family
elderly grandparents and great
grandparents dying without with nothing
and I just I'd like to have a better
quality of life when I'm older I guess
you're already on your way in a
spectacular fashion you're not dying
with nothing
yeah
how old are you and your husband
I'm 44 he's 46. yeah what does he do for
a living
he's an electrician
yeah he's already increased his income
does he work for himself now
no no he works for a utility company
yeah but he's still a young man and you
know he a natural progression for him to
be to start his own company and become a
millionaire just in that business alone
plus what Dave's already laid out for
you guys I just think this is so
fear-based that you haven't been able to
look at your own life and your own
reality and see how good you're doing
yeah one-third of the people that we've
studied that became millionaires did so
on six-figure income or less
and that's you wow that's you wow okay
so far I mean you just now got over a
hundred right
right just just in the last year yeah
yeah and so you did everything to this
point that you've done on less than a
hundred thousand dollars a year and you
told me the house is worth what
right right around 700. okay and you owe
100 so that's a 600 000 Equity I said
700 I was wrong okay so you have a 600
000 equity and if you've got 200 250 000
in your 401ks in Roth IRAs which you
need to go look up tonight you all need
to sit down and talk about this
because you're you're stewing about this
and don't even know the numbers
that that because sometimes just knowing
the numbers will relax you
so here's the thing let's pretend that
you got
um
uh 300 000 in there that's nine hundred
thousand dollars
okay very close to a million you follow
me 600 on the house plus three in the
other very close to a millionaire 44
years old that's a long way from dying
old and broke
yeah
and so yeah John deloney talks about
when you're running into these emotional
things and you're you're running the uh
the catastrophes over and over in your
head that facts are your friends they'll
they'll kick the drama queen out of your
brain
facts okay facts will do that so sit
down look at the facts because here's a
fact okay let's say that uh your net
worth grows at an average of 10 a year
because you're invested in good mutual
funds and real estate does well in the
Seattle Market which it traditionally
has done for the last 30 years okay now
Seattle could screw it up and you know
cause it to fall in on itself like some
of these other cities have done but
let's just assume that Seattle continues
to be a Boom Town okay
and so
if that happens your million dollars is
going to double every seven years
so you're 44 at 51 it's going to be 2
million at um
at 58
it's going to be 4 million
at 65 it's going to be 8 million and
that's if you add nothing to it
see what I mean by Factory State numbers
yeah facts are your friends
that's if things go up 10 a year if you
got your mutual funds and your and your
real estate goes up 10 a year now it may
or may not go up that much it may be a
little bit less but I'm not that far off
my point is not is that you know it's
going to double if it doesn't double
every seven years it's going to double
every eight years you know whatever it
is it's still going to be pretty close
and that's without adding anything to it
and you're going to continue to add to
it so you're you know you your chances
of becoming
your relative that died broke
is close to zero
I mean you're doing so good way to Go
Allison go get you a mirror and pat
yourself on the back